this video is brought to you by
wondershare filmora 10.
[Music]
what's up wisecrack michael here and i'm
back in a heavily sanitized wisecrack
studio
please people wear your freaking mask
anyway
today i've got disney on my brain and
not just because my nostalgic mom keeps
sending me this photo
and who can blame me they basically own
or license
everything i love and everything i hate
and that's not to mention the new season
of the mandalorian because they own
star wars also x-men that's right they
own the x-people
and just take a gander at the top
grossing films last year and you'll be
greeted by one name
and one name only see from endgame to
aladdin from frozen 2 to toy story 4
disney made 7 of the top 10 highest
grossing films of 2019
and while this feat is impressive even
for the big mouse
it's not exactly something new in fact
many of the
top 50 highest grossing films of all
time were either
made by or later bought by disney now
maybe for some of you this doesn't
matter as long as you get that marvel
cinematic goodness injected into your
eyeballs a few times a year
and i totally get it but what if i told
you that disney's ever broadening
artistic reach is actually
bad for culture and not just because
they made the worst
star war how let's find out in this
wisecrack edition on how disney ruined
culture
and i guess spoilers ahead for films you
absolutely saw if you were ever a child
but before we get into it i wanna give a
shout out to this week's sponsor
wondershare filmora
we've all been picking up new hobbies
since early march and if you're thinking
about starting your own channel then you
should check it out
wondershare filmora is a simple to use
video editing program which is
comparable and more affordable than
other big brands you might know
filmora isn't just for simple edits
either since it includes advanced
features like chroma keying video
stabilization and speed duration
clipping here at wisecrack until
recently we haven't been able to shoot
in our regular studio with fancy cameras
and lights
but editing with wondershare filmora we
could combat some of our issues
the new update includes some awesome key
features like color match keyframing
motion tracking and audio ducking
so you can create a professional looking
video the best part is that the
interface is user friendly
so you don't have to worry about
spending too much time googling
tutorials
click the link in the description to
check it out for yourself if you comment
on our pinned comment you could win a
license to get the software for free so
let us know what you would create in
filmora now
back to the show in the past few decades
disney has gone from an industry giant
to an absolute behemoth acquiring
everything from the muppets to pixar to
marvel to star wars to most recently
21st century fox
of course disney's game of hungry hungry
hippos but for intellectual property
goes
way back to the beginning according to
the company's own telling founder walt
disney moved to los angeles almost a
hundred years ago with and i quote
a lot of hopes but little else how
wholesome
four years later disney got his first
taste of success with oswald the lucky
rabbit
the only catch when disney tried to make
another round of these cartoons he found
out that his distributor had gone behind
his back and poached all of his
animators
worse upon reading the fine print of his
contract disney realized he didn't even
own the rights to oswald his distributor
did and thus like a super
villain's origin story our intrepid
young walt vows to never get screwed
again or as disney.com puts it he saw to
it that he owned
everything that he made after that
disney set up shop in a studio that is
five minutes away from wisecrack
headquarters
and is now a high-end grocery store here
he created his most
iconic character from then on disney
became a veritable creative and
financial powerhouse by 1937 it would
break all box office records with the
release of snow white and the seven
dwarves
early on though the success was
predicated on a simple formula
find an existing story make it as cute
and wholesome as possible to maximize
your potential audience
and then dive into your scrooge mcduck
sized money pool
of course you might think this is fine
after all pop culture is by definition
entertainment aimed at the largest
possible audience and disney definitely
had one thing
an aesthetic you know round faces saucer
eyes big goofy grins and if the kids
love
it how could it be bad but as we've
mentioned before
disney's reign of cuteness was not a
happy accident or mere coincidence
walt was basically ruthless in his quest
to make all things adorable and in the
process disney has spent the last 100
years acquiring stories
adapting them and ultimately twisting
their original artistic intentions
beyond recognition
all of which is to say is all this
cuteness actually super
uncute but to see the disney method in
action let's dissect an early example
pinocchio for the uninitiated the story
revolves around the titular puppet who
just wants to be
a real boy as the magical blue fairy
tells him his wish will be granted if he
proves to be brave
truthful and unselfish and someday you
will be a real boy
a real boy but pinocchio's not about
that life he runs away from home joins a
puppet show and
lies to the blue fairy about it which
famously leads to this
the fairy lets him off the hook but
pinocchio doesn't stay out of trouble
for long he soon whisked away on an
all-expense trip to the dubiously named
pleasure island
there pinocchio and his resort buddies
engage in all sorts of vices from
drinking to smoking to gambling
only to find out that they're turning
into donkeys
but with the help of his cricket
companion pinocchio narrowly escapes
only to learn that his daddy got lost at
sea looking for him it says here he
uh he went looking for you and uh he was
swallowed by a whale pinocchio then
sacrifices his little wooden life to
save the old man from the literal belly
of the whale
but lo and behold now that pinocchio is
good he's brought back to life by the
blue fairy
but this time as a real boy and everyone
lives happily ever after
if only life was that easy but what if i
told you that the author of pinocchio
carlo colotti
never intended for his story to give
children that warm fuzzy feeling and
that once disney had bought their rights
to the story
the company whitewashed pinocchio to fit
the big mouse's cutesy aesthetic
if you have any doubt then i present to
you the original ending of colodi's
pinocchio without loss of time
they tied his arms past a running noose
round his throat and
hung him to the branch of a tree called
the big oak a tempestuous
northerly wind began to blow and roar
angrily
and it beat the puppet from side to side
making him swing violently like the
clatter of a bell ringing for a wedding
and the swinging gave him atrocious
spasms it's really bad
his breath failed him and he could say
no more
shut his eyes opened his mouth stretched
his legs and gave a long shutter
and hung stiff and insensible
you heard right kolodi had pinocchio
gruesomely hanged
this inspired so much angry fan mail
that his editor demanded he bring the
puppet back to life and continue the
series
which he begrudgingly did in collodi's
defense though pinocchio being hanged
was pretty much
par for the course it's hard to see in
disney's version but pinocchio was
intended to be a tongue-in-cheek albeit
bleak
morality tale the simple moral be good
or suffer throughout the story we see a
mean-spirited and rude pinocchio
a stand-in for all misbehaving children
robbed starved stand
and also his legs get sawed off but
we're not supposed to feel especially
sorry for him his actions cause
all of his suffering oh and if that
wasn't enough collodi also heaped on the
psychological abuse making pinocchio at
one point think he had killed geppetto
and the blue fairy which i didn't even
know was possible
and while you and i growing up in a
media diet full of high saturated disney
cuteness might find the story repulsive
it's pretty run of the mill if you're
familiar with old german folklore
more recently we've seen similarly
gothic tones in children's books like
lemony snicket's a series of unfortunate
events
now let's be fair maybe you don't want
your kid's bedtime story ending in
gruesome death
but there's still something unsettling
about the way a media giant like disney
can take a beloved fairy tale
purge it of its original intentions and
thus rewrite the narrative in our
collective memories
instead of saying faithful to kalodi's
artistic intention
disney did what it would continue to do
for decades buy a story
bleach it in a caustic vat of cuteness
and pump it out in exchange for
cold hard cash gone were the dark
satiric overtones and in their place
were syrupy lions like this
thank you m'lady he deserved to be a
real boy as for pinocchio himself he
went from being
a total frat pro to the naive piece of
pine we know and loved today
in the process his character design
underwent similar changes with walt
disney scrapping the angular designs
found in collodi's story
for a character model that can best be
described as what would happen if mickey
mouse had a baby with a tree
obviously collodi's estate was kind of
pissed with his grandson suing disney's
italian distributor for infringing on
the moral copyright of the story
now i know what you're thinking it's an
adaptation artists are allowed to adapt
and sure
they are plenty of great art exist
because someone took an existing story
and made it their own
sometimes undercutting the original like
pride and prejudice but
add zombies more seriously something
like there will be blood took the first
few pages of upton sinclair's equally
awesome book oil
and basically threw away everything else
but nobody would accuse paul thomas
anderson of whitewashing oil and i don't
think pratt and prejudice in zombies has
somehow cheapened
the jane austen novel maybe part of the
difference lies in formula
and scale pta hasn't created a billion
dollar industry by stripping stories of
their content and replacing them with a
deranged daniel day lewis
disney on the other hand regularly takes
stories like pinocchio or sleeping
beauty or hell the hunchback of notre
dame
and throws them into the commercial meat
grinder worse
they've been doing this pretty
consistently for the past hundred years
seriously if you were to put all the
disney films on a spinning wheel
whatever you'd land on would likely be
an adaptation in which the original
story has been blanched artistically
ground down and pumped out as a cute
little disney sausage
actually why don't we just spin that
wheel and find
out ah yes the 1989 classic the little
mermaid
timeless story in which a young mermaid
makes a faustian bargain with a sea
witch to gain legs so she can win the
hand of a hunky prince
based on the hans christian andersen
tale of the same name
disney's retelling strips the story of a
lot of its darker and more religious
overtones in the big mouse's version
we're treated to a love story that ends
with a happily ever after the prince
ultimately realizes that he really digs
this mermaid the mermaid frees herself
from the sea witch's curse
the prince harpoons said sea witch and
all is basically right with the world
the message true love saves all but the
source material
isn't nearly as happy or uplifting
that's because anderson flatly rejected
this message
first of all his story portrays love
primarily as
suffering for example anderson's mermaid
doesn't just give away her voice in
exchange for legs
but also endures the pain of being
stabbed
every time she takes a step nevertheless
she delights in dancing for the prince
and making him happy what's more
in anderson's telling the prince never
returns the mermaid's affection
instead he marries a local princess so
yeah
rough deal but there's a reason for this
anderson wanted the mermaid to be saved
not by love but by sacrifice at the
start of the story the mermaid despairs
not just because she's half fish but
also because she doesn't have a soul and
won't be able to chill with her prince
in heaven
in fact the whole bargain with the witch
revolves around ariel
gaining a soul if she manages to kiss
her true love
but as anderson explained to a friend he
never wanted the mermaid to gain a soul
simply because she fell in love
with a straight up hunk he thought such
an ending would be explicitly
wrong in short anderson would have
despised disney's ending in which a kiss
and a strategic boat crash
saves the day see in anderson's tale the
mermaid saves the day with a christ-like
sacrifice where she gives up her life
and love to save the prince
and lo and behold she's rewarded for her
good deeds and turned into a gentle
spirit
if she helps mankind for the next 300
years she'll be rewarded
with a soul hooray well according to
anderson this is the more
natural more divine path though it
probably wouldn't have jacked up
disney's 1989 stock prices
and at this point we could keep rambling
off examples the
real pocahontas is not a story about the
freedom to love who you choose
it's about colonists kidnapping a native
american woman and murdering her husband
the original sleeping beauty is
literally about a woman being
non-consensually impregnated in her
sleep and giving
birth to twins also in her sleep now
we're not going to say disney should be
making more films about assault because
that'd be horrible
however the general disney meat grinder
which polishes off any rough and
unsavory edges
comes with consequences in the case of
pocahontas it's a very shitty history
lesson that some people might never
question
but that's just the first of many ways
that disney's storytelling might
actually be a major disservice for
developing young minds
that's because most of the stories
disney adapts are fairy tales
and while these stories may often be
dark and complex and vaguely disturbing
they also offer children a symbolic
template for understanding the world
for example in a children's cancer
clinic researchers found that patients
were able to use
fairy tales to express and cope with
their anxieties one child
for example identified with the big bad
wolf in little red riding hood
venting his frustration and anger by
drawing an oversized wolf with
massive teeth another child drew a
comically tiny wolf as an expression of
confidence and bravery in the face of
his struggles
here we see how the darkness of fairy
tales can actually offer a light to
children confronting adversity
but disney often strips these fairy
tales of their bite
instead inserting a bland wholesome
narrative as we saw with pinocchio and
the little mermaid
and ironically in the process disney's
developed new narratives that are in
their own rights potentially quite
destructive as psychologist susan darker
smith points out
young girls who identify with characters
like cinderella or belle from beauty and
the beast are more likely to end up in
abusive relationships as adults while
interviewing victims of domestic abuse
darker smith found that many identified
with the heroines of these stories in
which
love conquers all believing that if
their love is strong enough they can
change their partner's behavior
of course the reality is tragically
different ironically by peddling a
convenient narrative in which all the
world's problems can be solved by true
love
disney fails to give children any tools
for navigating real life problems
and that was kind of the whole point of
fairy tales to convey the darker and
crueler aspects of
life so as to better prepare children
for the realities of adulthood
of course this all begs the question
should disney care
according to the legendary and
incendiary free market economist milton
friedman
definitely not he argued that companies
don't have the same responsibilities
that people do
a person might have a responsibility to
be a nice neighbor
or recycle while a company's only
responsibility
is to make more money and friedman's
definition of corporate responsibility
has pretty much become gospel
in other words disney will only do what
is required to make the most amount of
money
regardless of the social consequences
it's the capitalist raison dead of
companies the world over and it explains
why disney operates a cuteness factory
indeed when disney went dark in the
1970s and 80s
it put out a series of grimmer edgier
films like the black cauldron
that were huge box office failures and
nearly brought about the collapse of the
great empire of mouse
the so-called disney renaissance of the
90s was a major course correction back
into the sentimental cuteness that has
sustained the company ever since
and it's no wonder cuteness after all
has a very particular way of
hijacking our brains and more
importantly it's cells
studies have shown that cuteness
increases our concentration
a useful trick to make sure humans pay
close attention to their adorable young
or you know pay more attention to a
dysfunctional snowman
even more telling when volunteers were
hooked up to an mri machine and
bombarded with cute images their nucleus
accumbens also known as the pleasure
center of the brain
lit up and started pumping out dopamine
in other words when viewers saw mickey
mouse's adorable body bob
up and down on screen 100 years ago they
were unwittingly receiving the first
micro doses of disney branded brain
candy
interestingly enough the phenomenon of
cuteness being used for potentially
nefarious purposes
has a name cultural theorist joshua paul
dale calls it
evil cute and while dale specifically
cites gambling machines that use cute
cartoon kittens as an example
it's not hard to argue that disney's
precious animated friends might also
qualify in the end cuteness is just a
means for disney to pad its bottom line
regardless if it's telling stories that
are ultimately good for children
and while you might not be too
devastated to hear that disney sabotaged
your favorite 16th century tale about a
naughty sentient puppet
the disney vacation of storytelling
becomes more viscerally upsetting when
the big mouse starts screwing around
with more iconic cultural works you
catch my drift
ever since disney acquired the
universe's most beloved franchise
fans have increasingly despaired at the
creative choices that resulted
the last trilogy began with sentimental
fan service befitting
of disney it seemed to briefly flirt
with darkness and complexity in the last
jedi suggesting star wars wouldn't fall
completely into the pits of cuteness
and then this
that's right disney quickly course
corrected and opted for a sweet
conclusion based on a magical kiss
romantic sacrifice and of course
everyone you care about is jedi royalty
now ray skywalker
all of which is to say there's no
property or franchise which disney won't
find a way to wrap its cute little
tentacles
around so what happens now honestly
probably nothing good as disney
continues to grow which it's almost
certainly going to do
it's reasonable to worry that we'll see
an expansion of their blanket philosophy
of cuteness and as we've seen in the
past that cuteness probably comes at the
expense of story nuance and morality
it definitely makes us nervous for the
future of a franchise like x-men
it's hard to imagine disney signing off
on something as subversive as logan and
as disney continues to gobble up more
and more of the media we love we're
worried that there won't be space for
grittier
darker stories for grown up fairy tales
if you will
but what do you guys think is our
loathing for the disney empire totally
reasonable and warranted
or do we sound like overly quarantined
haters let us know in the comments
as always huge thanks to our patrons for
your support hit that subscribe button
like it's a fairy tale you're ready to
ruin for buckets of money and as always
thanks for watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]